so I'm going to tell you about the goat
problem
yeah it's mean he's not the greatest of
all time but it's you know it's good
enough we'll do it it's all right this
is kind of like a school kind of problem
uh but it's actually hard to solve for a
long time we did we only had an
approximation of the answer until
recently and we actually for the first
time have an exact answer to the goat
problem so let me tell you what it is it
does involve a goat do you got like a
fence going around a circular field and
you have tethered a goat to the fence so
to the side of that Circle so this is
some sort of rope of length what do we
call this length R so the field has a
radius of one why not and now we're
going to tether a goat to the side of
the field and let's say the Rope has
length R okay let's there you go let's
do a little gate that is confusing that
we made it up well yeah it's kind of odd
because if you look at where the goat
can reach it's kind of a radius of a
circle so this is where the goat can
graze
so this is a fixed point where you've
tethered the goat the goat can now roam
as freely as that tether will let him
and so he can graze on the field and
they question in the goat problem is how
long should the Rope be if you want the
goat to graze and half a field and that
feels like something you might be able
to solve maybe with school level maths
you can get quite far with school level
maths let's see how far we can get it
feels easy yeah yeah it feels easy and
this is why people are so frustrated
when you tell them this problem I'll
tell you what I I gather this is a
problem that they used to teach a lot in
U.S Navy academies I don't know if
they're teaching this as an example of
being used to difficult problems because
they would teach this in these Navy
academies and they would say and you can
do this there's no exact answer and
people were frustrated and got surely
this must have a exact answer but no
exact answer was found until recently
and it involved some hard maths how old
is school student attacked this program
so let's do another Circle let's make
that the center of the field do a little
extra center of the field and let's say
my goat can eat some sort of circular
area like this something like that so my
goat can reach all the way to the fence
here and my goat could reach all the way
to the fence
here and then he can eat all this kind
of curve here so it's a fraction of a
circle with a radius of R this angle
here that I've just made let's give it a
name
um Alpha I'll use Alpha for the angle hi
nard okay so good it's a good name for
now for an angle good grassy number it's
grassy Alpha Alfalfa you think Alpha is
grassic Alfalfa yeah I don't know so
this is how the U would start to
calculate this with a bit of trick I'm
not going to go through all the details
of the trick because it's boring so what
is the area of the field well it's a
circular field it has a radius of one so
you use your traditional formula for
working out the area of a circle and the
field is going to have an area pi
uh but we want the goat to eat half the
field so pi over two
copy that okay pi over 2 is what the
goat we want the goat to have yeah
exactly all right now you've given us
his eating yeah well some of his eating
area there yeah so this is some of his
eating areas and I've kind of missed off
some bits here I'll come to that as well
so what I'm going to do is a little bit
of school level trig so when I say trig
I mean you know it's angles and signs
and causes and triangles and things like
that the length of the Rope is going to
be
two cars and then it's Alpha over two
it's half of this angle here but I've
kind of doesn't help me work out the
length of the Rope that's what I'm
trying to work out because now I've just
sort of change the problem because I
need to work out what the angle is okay
so that's what we're doing next so that
part is not so hard working out the
angle is where it starts to get hard
okay so if you calculate this what we
can calculate is Alpha is a fraction of
a full circle so I know that this area
here is a fraction of a full circle of
radius R I can also work out if I start
at the center here a different Circle
because I've missed off these bits here
so let's try and get those back this is
a fraction of a circle with a radius one
and so we could talk about this angle
and we could work out if I worked out at
that angle it's going to be related to
Alpha so I'm not going to do all those
calculations but we can work out this
fraction of a circle as well and then
add it together and then we've got this
area but oh no wait hang on this diamond
shape that I've got here can you see
it's overlapped so I've got an overlap
kind of like two triangles and it's all
overlapping you remove the overlap and
then you've got the area the goat has
eaten I've not gone through the trick
details because we would just be here
looking at signs and causes for a long
time but this is what you would get pi
plus Alpha so that's not angle COS of
alpha
minus sine of alpha that's the area that
the goat is eating hopefully you can see
why I didn't go through all the details
because it's actually quite a nasty
calculation to do what we're going to
get then if we solve this is we're going
to find the angle Alpha and then that's
okay because I have a formula for the
length of the Rope there that's where we
come we feel we do one last step and
then we'll get that length of the Rope
so it's actually calculating that angle
that's important for us for now and we
want this area that the goat is eating
to be half the field
and half the field is pi over 2. so we
set this equal to pi over 2. we're
trying to solve this equation it's not a
particularly nice equation it's trig and
in fact this is difficult to calculate
because it's called a transcendental
equation uh so it sounds like a nice
name but it's a difficult kind of
equation to solve a nice equation to
solve is what we call a polynomial and
that's the kind of things you get where
you have x squared plus x minus six
those kind of things they're quite easy
to solve and when you do you get an
exact answer at the end so I can then
say x is equal to and I could write
something down it might have square
roots and horrible things in it but I
can give you an exact answer
for a transcendental equation I'm afraid
there is no method for giving you an
exact answer the only way to solve it
and it's the angle we're trying to solve
is approximations it's the only way to
solve it and so that has been done so we
have an approximate answer for that
angle so we're getting closer and the
approximate answer is it's about 109
degrees plus some decimals it's 109
degrees
0.1885 something something and we're not
quite finished the goat problem because
I want to know the length of the rope
and then really the last step is the
easy step
um yes the easy bit of trig so showed us
that the length of the Rope should be
two cars Alpha over two and that's going
to be and again it's only an approximate
answer but it is this answer one point
one five eight seven two eight four
seven three oh one dot dot dot so just
longer than the radius of the field so
it is yeah it's a little bit longer than
the radius of the field I would have
expected if you asked me to guess I
would have gone
um root 2 square root of two something
like that that's what the anti expected
it to be I think that's where some
people get frustrated with this because
they want it to be an answer like that
but it's not what we've got and there is
well until recently there is no exact
answer it's that dot dot dot that shows
you it's not exact it's a decimal goes
on forever and yes I mean we've got an
equal sign but equal dot dot dot we can
make this more accurate you know you can
make better approximations but I could
never tell you like an exact answer like
a little equation or a little formula
telling you what the length of this rope
is what's surprising about that problem
why surprisingly hard is because the
three-dimensional version of it is
easier the three-dimensional version is
a bird in a cage imagine having a
spherical cage of radius one and you've
got a bird tied with a thread and in
that burden then fly wherever it's
allowed to fly limited by that thread so
you can fly around what does the length
of the thread need to be to be half the
volume of the sphere that should be a
harder question it turns out to be
easier
um yeah you can actually Solve IT here's
the answer the equation you get to solve
is something like this it's three
R to power four
minus eight R cubed
plus eight equals zero I mean it's a
traditional mathematical equation it's a
polynomial and if it's a polynomial that
will have an exact answer it might have
square roots in it it might look a bit
nasty but it will have an exact answer
in fact when this was solved Marshall
Frasier was a mathematician who solved
this he did give an approximation for
this answer here's approximation was
that thread was 1.22
eight five four five and then something
something
uh so he did originally give an
approximation but a few years ago
um an exact answer was given and this is
kind of nice for me it was a couple of
friends of mine who did it so this is
nice I get to give them a shout out this
is Nick and Graham Jameson actually
Graham was my lecturer at University and
Nick is my friend for other reasons uh
so hey hey guys this is really nice and
they actually worked out the exact
answer for the bird version of the goat
problem and it's this monster all right
you ready and it is a monster so are you
ready I'm ready my friends actually
broke it down into two parts because
it's such a difficult thing to write
down they Define something called a and
this is a horrible thing as well so a is
16 over 9 plus 4 over 3 and inside a
couple of brackets we've got four plus
square root of eight Cube rooted and
then we add on another bracket here
which is going to be four minus square
root of eight in a bracket and we're
going to cube root that as well and then
that's just halfway there because then
their length of the Rope thread for the
bird was going to be two-thirds it was a
half of square root of a that's where
that a comes in minus and then we've got
another horrible thing another square
root
of 16 thirds minus a wow plus 128 over
27 and a square root of a down there as
well whoa it's ridiculous isn't it it's
outrageous but it is an actual exact
answer to this problem so I could write
that down as a decimal number you could
write that down as a decimal number but
I mean that's what Marshall Frazier did
he didn't want to calculate that
outrageous expression so he said well
I'll just approximate it and maybe
that's kind of more useful in some
situations but in this case this is a
solvable problem
um actually in higher Dimensions it gets
easier if you keep going up into the
dimensions four dimensions five
Dimensions so on and the Goat problem
the length of the Rope starts to tend to
an answer and it tends to one point uh
four one four uh
two one dot dot always the square root
of two
it's it actually tends to the square
root of two so it actually gets easier
somehow as you're going down higher and
higher dimensions and I would have
expected the answer to be square root of
two yeah just intuitively that would be
my guess my square root of two feels
right to me maybe that's just me but it
just feels right but it's the
two-dimensional one that caused all the
problems it's just really really hard to
solve uh well until recently we now have
an exact answer this has finally been
solved it's been solved by a German
mathematician called Ingo audish and to
solve it he actually had to use some
higher level maths he used complex
analysis so he calculated that uses
complex numbers and he calculated the
areas using functions in complex numbers
they were like sine functions and cos
functions but now they're using complex
numbers instead of the regular numbers
and worked out the area using this kind
of maths and he found an exact answer he
found that he found the exact answer for
that angle Alpha once you've got that
then you can stick it into the formula
we had before and it looks like this so
our angle Alpha that's what we wanted to
know it's an integral it's a complex
integral that's what that symbol means
and we're going to evaluate this when we
do evaluate it at Z is a variable and oh
what we've got is going to be Z minus 3
pi over 8 equals to pi over four this is
where you evaluate it and then this is
the function it's Z divided by the sine
of Z minus Z
COS of Z minus pi over 2. put that in a
bracket and let's integrate that that's
the DZ that's how you do that kind of
thing and we're dividing by another
integral which is kind of similar whoa
It's outrageous isn't it uh but it's an
exact answer I mean for the first time
we've got Alpha equals
a formula and how long's the rope and
how long's the Rope I mean I'm just
going to go back to our approximation
because it was easier to work out which
was what Ivy I said earlier which is
1.158 so it gets pretty much the same
it's just not only it is the same it is
the same in fact I will tell you this
it's really nice to have an exact answer
I mean a formula for the first time
although this formula is hard to work
out and if you wanted to work it out
you'd be better off approximating the
values anyway so it's still calculated
by approximations uh but hey we've got
the first formula for the angle Alpha so
you would then put that into you know
and take that Alpha
put it straight into
the formula that we had with our trick
so the trig is still there uh as our
final step
and that and that's just going to change
the length by like a billionth of a
nanometer I have no idea because I don't
think it's actually been calculated
because it's hard
so we know the exact number but no one
would probably bother calculator you
couldn't put that into a wall for an
alpha uh I don't think we can I'd even
Wolfram Alpha I think would struggle to
calculate this answer why did this
mathematician do this why did he spend
his time just because I don't want to
speak for him but I can guess if you
want I mean it is an exercise in his
methods in mathematics it's it's
practice and then you know this is not
an important problem
uh but it is
um a way to practice you know your tools
and then you can use that practice one
day in the future for problems you do
care about okay here's a puzzle for you
it involves rotating a die using the
numbers on the face and moving it around
this board
it's the latest brain Bender from Jane
Street today's episode sponsor and to
check out the details have a look at
their website there's a nice clear
explanation there and you'll also find a
wall of fame for people who have already
cracked the puzzle maybe your name could
be added see the link on screen and in
the video description and while you're
there why not check out some of the
latest jobs and opportunities and things
going on at Jane Street I've got
officers in the likes of New York Hong
Kong and London a career at Jane Street
could be just the thing for someone with
a puzzle solving mind like you
every row column and the diagonals I
also want them to include a club A Heart
a spade and a diamond it's like a Sudoku
it is like a stoker so try it out it
should be the same kind of thing as this
doku there is a solution I'm not trying
to catch you out